guten morgen nach berlin also wir sind
ich habe mich kurz vorher bei den
belgiern erkundet das heißt es also es
wird ein bisschen anders ausgesprochen
aber jeder weiß glaube ich wo wir sind
das ist ungefähr 25 kilometer von
antwerpen entfernt und wenn man aus dem
ruhrgebiet angereist so knapp zwei
stunden 45 dann ist man hier ein kurs
ich geh jetzt mal ein stück nach links
zur seite kann er mich an meinen einmal
bisschen schwenken wir stehen ja vor dem
werk in den pools von pfizer hier liegt
die hoffnung und wenn herr wieder gerade
nochmal auf die zahlen geblickt hat und
noch mal noch mal gesagt hat dass man
sich an weihnachten am riemen reißen
sollen möglichst auf kontakte verzichten
soll
sind wir hier im zentrum der hoffnung
und zwar ist das der tabernakel der
hoffnung weil dahinter verbirgt sich das
wo wir alle sehnsüchtig darauf warten
dass ist der impfstoff der uns ein
besseres leben wieder bescheren soll
und gestern habe ich an der ehemalige
standen in amsterdam ich muss sagen das
war auch für uns alle ein sehr
emotionaler moment gestern abend noch
das wirklich sehr sehr eindrucksvolle
interview von herrn seien dem chef von
biotech das war wirklich sehr sehr
ergreifend was er da gesagt hat und noch
mal zu sagen was da eigentlich für eine
leistung hinter steckt und hier hinter
uns werden die impfstoffe produziert und
in kühl lkw es dann durch europa durch
die welt gefahren und auch hier kommt
der impfstoff für deutschland her
ich habe michael walter katholik habe
ein makel der hoffnung tabernakel ist in
der katholischen kirche der reich
verzierte schrein in dem die reliquien
sind also tatsächlich dann doch die
hoffnung ich hoffe du gehst jetzt nicht
auf die knie weil dann bis zu 1000 bild
und bietet das linke jetzt nicht nur an
aber sag mal ist denn da ist an der
bewegung was weiß man dann wird da schon
ausgeliefert
also ist sind wohl gestern abend die
ersten lkws gefahren hinter uns ist
wirklich reges treiben
einer von security ist gerade auf uns
zugekommen auch wie in amsterdam und
sehr freundlich hier ist das ein
bisschen anders als in deutschland man
sagt wir möchten gern ihre pressekarte
haben die möchten wir fotografieren
hier steht hier total sicher was man
jetzt nicht sehen kann hinter uns auch
die
die bushaltestelle weise also wir sind
absolut richtig und er sagt wir dürfen
ja alles machen wohl drauf wir bitte
verzichten mögen ist es leute
anzusprechen wir möchten bitte keine
expliziten werk einrichtungen zeigen das
ist jetzt hier vor der tür ein bisschen
schwierig und mit so ein paar
stahlrohren da kann er jetzt auch keiner
irgendwas kopieren was da ist nur das
kann man sich dann vielleicht zu hause
im garten stellen aber letztendlich
passiert ja nichts und ja hier ist
allerdings wesentlich mehr presse als
gestern vor der ehe man muss sagen alles
völlig entspannt ich glaube jeder er ist
sich hier im klaren was dass hierfür ein
für ein wichtiger ort ist es gibt aber
keine demonstranten wie gestern in
amsterdam
hier läuft wirklich alles alles ganz
glatt und die leute haben auch hinter
hinter den werkshallen etwas anderes zu
tun als sich jetzt mit kleinigkeiten
aufzuhalten
dahinter soll der impfstoff produziert
werden dahinter soll das produziert
werden was uns die normalität ein stück
weit zurück bringt damit wirklich auch
am 27 dezember so wie es herr spahn
gestern gesagt hat so wie es die politik
gesagt hat so wie auch die ema gestern
nochmal verlautbaren hat dass alles
seinen gewohnten gang läuft das dann
tatsächlich am 27 dezember geimpft
werden kann
von daher würde ich sagen mich spricht
die leute auch nicht anhalten nicht von
der arbeit ab und ich hoffe du musst du
nicht mit dem bus nach hause fahren
vielen vielen dank an dich du stehst für
uns seit gestern mehr oder weniger an
historischen orten ich danke dir zurück
nach berlin
danke
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren